okay we're gonna do guys we're gonna sit
10k off at Target we're gonna BLAP it
really quick and we're gonna warp to the
run spots that make sense
outstanding hey stand by
so hey guys here steel they got their
prophecy fleet up and then razor also
has an Oracle fleet so we should have
some interest some stuff about to happen
so it's going to be like this
we're going to portal through at the
same time the triage carriers are going
to jump just the treehouse carries first
everyone clear
oh crap I think
real to go Guardians get four Guardians
Alex
do this don't worry about that
now we're going to play some fun games
my heart's racing thunder relax always
alive primary is the Dominic's in five
four three two
Dominus
or put on me breaking work types lon
removing secondary's Vipers in the
Ullman his instruction pickup down dude
that revelation now now all needs on the
rep burnout to watch that charge up now
all danced on the damnation on the dance
on
chapter Shahir
all right so I'm carrying a hundred
times more than my ship is worth there
were some pirates chasing me this one
guy chased me through like five
different systems I need to get the
gather system this little rock right
here is worth about 166 million discs
for some people this might not be a big
deal but for me it's huge seller 4.2
very nice and produce for them two days
19 hours 11 minutes 44 seconds we can
expect to make eight to ten million
around there 5156 grit okay good and
we've got my modules to fit in here the
ship speed is actually pretty good at
getting 4k a second we record that now
by adding on some armor buffer
up success yeah thanks dude
shocking so much fun oh yeah such fun
fellas down now like less than a week Oh
haha
okay in silos down giving some stats and
stuff portal portal front gate is really
diverse skills to one module as we you
see and the best item 9.1
discover unique locating I'm Sophie -
secretary